قبل حوالي نصف ساعه من الان يعني اعلنت
السلطات التركيه في ولايه كهرمان مرعش
انقاذ طفله بقيت تحت الانقاض لمده 99 ساعه
هذا مشهد مختلف تماما
في هذه الطفله
نعم نعم نعم قبل نصف ساعه او ساعه على
الاكثر هذا الخبر جاء يعني حياه اخرى كتبت
لهذه الطفله ولكل احباء هذه الطفله لا شك
ان يعني سعاده لا يمكن وصفها لاقارب هذه
الطفله وذويها عاشوها عندما تم اخراجها
على قيد الحياه
يعني
لا يمكن لاحد ان يتوقع ان يصبر طفل على
هذا على هذه المده الطويله في هذا البرد
القارس يعني حقيقه هذا البرد
يعني من احد فصول الشتاء صحيح ان الشتاء
تاخر في تركيا لكن جاءت موجه شتاء قاسيه
جدا جدا جدا ومع بقاء
عالقين تحت الانقاض في هذه الظروف يعني لا
احد يمكن ان يتوقع ان تستمر المعجزات او
ان يصمد الاطفال تحت الانقاض الى هذه
الدرجات القصص
الامل موجود على اقله يعني ولو كانت
الفلوس جدا وايضا زيدان يعني كان هناك
ملاحظه وانت تحدثني بانه قبل نصف ساعه تم
انقاذ طفله يعني وكان الاطفال هم اكثر
قدره على الصمود ايذاء ما يحصل هل كان
هناك ملاحظه فعلا بانه دائما او معظم
الوقت الاطفال هم من يخرجوا احياء من تحت
الانقاد
نعم لا شك يعني هذه الانباء فعلا هذه
ظاهره لاحظناها في التغطيه دائما نشاهد
صور الاطفال وهم ناجين بينما مع الاسف
ذويهم يفارقون الحياه ربما هي يعني لا
يوجد تفسير حقيقه ربما الاباء او الاهالي
قاموا باعتضان اطفالهم لحمايتهم فت نعم
توفي الاب او الام وبقي الطفل على قيد
الحياه ربما هذا سبب يعني لا ندري حقيقه
او ربما وسائل الاعلام تحاول التركيز يعني
مشهد طفل يخرج من تحت الانقاض هو في حقيقه
مشهد مؤثر للجميع لكن لا شك ان هناك اعتقد
ان ربما الاباء اثناء محاوله الهروب
يحاولون احتضان اطفالهم وهذا وهذا الموضوع
يعني ليس ليس فقط للعالقين تحت الانقاب
حتى الاشخاص الذين التقيناهم واجرينا معهم
مقابلات لقناه العربيه تقريبا جمله واحده
لدى الجميع اي نتحدث معه يقول احتضنت طفلي
وركضت